the botox chemical is physically
addictive
i think botox is like getting your hair
colored or your nails done
it's not like you have to but you're
gonna want to botox is so
simple anyone can give an injection or
my two-year-old can push a plunger
but it's also very easy to mess
someone's face up
botox will make you look emotionless
rita can you tell i'm happy right now
that's you happy hi my name is dr rita
lintner i am a board-certified
dermatologist from new york city
i spend the majority of my day doing
injectables and lasers
hi i'm dr jordana hershthal and i'm a
board-certified dermatologist in boca
raton florida
and i love talking with patients about
their aesthetic goals and helping them
see
the full picture and we're here today to
debunk myths about botox
myths from social media botox is toxic
to your body this is not true
but it's good to know the history of
botox
botox gets that name recognition it was
the first neuromodulator that was fda
approved so it's a household name like
kleenex and xerox and so today we're
going to be referring
to botox as that umbrella term where
we're discussing
all of the neuromodulators that are
currently fda approved so
botox contains a purified protein known
as botulinum toxin
which is derived from a bacteria that
causes
botulism which is toxic to your body
however
botox used appropriately in appropriate
dosing
is very safe and very effective there
are over
3000 studies proving its efficacy
and safety the other reason it is very
safe to use
is we know that it stays where we inject
it so it's not like you're getting botox
in your forehead and it's going
all over your body botox is limited to
where it is injected
and it is safely metabolized and
excreted by your body
in a few months i always tell patients
if botox was dangerous i literally
wouldn't have a pulse
i'm someone who puts like a hundred
units of botox
into my face and neck every four and a
half months and i have so for over a
decade
so there are certain medical conditions
that are contraindicated to the use of
botox
so you should have a very thorough
discussion with your provider before you
receive
a botox treatment botox is permanent so
let's debunk this one botox is
not permanent everybody metabolizes
botox differently one of the great
things
about botox is if you don't like the way
it looks
it's completely out of your system in
three to six months
but it's also the worst thing because if
you like the way it looks
you have to do it again there is a super
botox that's out on the horizon though
that's looking to get fda approved later
this year
it's going for fda approval for 11's in
between the eyebrows and i can tell you
confidently that it works and it's going
to have an indication that's going to be
longer than three to five months
some creams and serums work like botox
this is
absolutely false botox works at the
muscular
level at specifically the neuromuscular
junction
to prevent the muscle from contracting
there is currently
no serum cream or facial that can
penetrate
the skin deep enough to exert action
at the level of the muscle and if it
were true it would have to have
fda approval and it would not be
available over the counter
i completely agree i i like to tell
patients you're genetically programmed
to move your muscles in a certain way
and over time you get what we call
dynamic wrinkles which are lines
associated with muscle movement
and the way botox works is it builds in
resistance so that you can't over
utilize those muscles anymore
you can't crease them and it basically
helps to smooth everything out
so next myth getting botox is super
painful
uh i would have to say this one's false
the pain
of a botox needle is pretty minimal but
it is similar to
if you got like a splinter in your
finger or perhaps a bee sting
everybody's experience with pain is
different they're
insulin needles they're as small as you
can get
and it goes faster than people think
also so i think location on the face
does make a big difference in terms of
sensitivity and this relates to how
important it is
for your provider to really have a deep
understanding of anatomy
when you're getting any sort of
injectable on your face
i mean i can do a full face a full neck
of botox in probably under four minutes
and if people are really averse to
needles you can always topically numb
someone to help that pain dissipate
there are other little tricks
like vibration devices and also ice
and even for patients who are really
sensitive we break out the pronox which
is half dose laughing gas
and that always calms patients down
immediately
and leaves your system within five
minutes the botox chemical is
physically addictive i think botox
is like getting your hair colored or
your nails done this is how i like to
explain it to patients who ask me
if i do this once do i have to keep
doing this for the rest of my life it's
not like you have to but you're gonna
want to
so i always liken aesthetic treatments
like botox fillers and lasers
to maintaining any organ in your system
you get your teeth cleaned
two to four times a year whatever it is
you get your aesthetic treatments
because you're always aging these
treatments do not stop the aging process
but these treatments will help you age
the way
you want to age myth experts hear
the most botox is so simple anyone can
give an injection
on the one hand giving an injection
is very easy anyone can push a plunger
my two-year-old can push a plunger
but it's also very easy to mess
someone's face up
so it's really critical that your
provider has a deep understanding
of anatomy and how these medicines
affect
anatomy to give you reproducible
great aesthetic outcomes so jordana and
i are board-certified dermatologists
you know it took each of us over a
decade to get to the point where we were
able to put a syringe in our hands and
utilize the the medicine in it to create
facial aesthetics
both jordan and i still to this day we
take courses religiously
where we're learning from the best
international patients and
doing dissection courses and we're still
reading every day to really be the best
teachers that we can be for our patients
botox and fillers are the same i
love this myth because i probably
address it
at least once a day almost every line
on your face can be addressed with
filler
but not every line can be addressed with
botox
botox works at the level of the muscle
to relax muscles of contraction it is
preventing and diminishing
those static lines or lines at rest
fillers on the other hand
are used to address volume loss that
occurs in our face
as we age so we all have fat
compartments all over our face
and as we age they deflate and descend
with time
so we use fillers to restore that lost
volume and give a more youthful shape to
the face
botox injections need a lot of recovery
time
the only issue with botox is if you get
a bruise but there really isn't
down time there's about an hour after
the procedure where you will see
little bumps under the skin and that's
the solution of the botox
that's that was placed under the skin
you are taking a needle and putting it
into your skin so you just want to make
sure that you're
not doing anything to really thin your
blood which would increase the chances
of getting a bruise so ideally
not drinking alcohol the night before or
even caffeine the morning of really
helps
if you have a really high tendency
towards bruising it's nice to take oral
arnica
i can always tell when i'm injecting a
patient i call it the booze ooze
it's like this slow ooze after you
inject and i know that they've had
a glass of wine or a martini the night
before
my only rule that i have for my patients
when botox goes in
is no exercising for six hours my only
rule is don't
touch the botox because i don't want you
spreading it to a different area
in the forehead or the glabella area
because
you could get into trouble with dropping
somebody's lid
so the muscles that keep the brow
elevated
will drop and then the patient will
appear to have a heavier lid
again these are not permanent side
effects but they are undesirable side
effects
botox accumulates in the body i wish
that was true
but unfortunately it does not every week
that your botox is in it's incrementally
decreases it's not like it just turns
off overnight
i will tell you in this pandemic i'm
noticing people are exercising more
and that's making their botox metabolize
a little bit faster so i get that
question a lot
you know how do we make my botox last
longer and it is dose dependent so
if you put more in it might not look so
natural for those first few weeks but it
should get you to last
a couple of weeks longer than when you
were using a lower dose
myths from pop culture botox will make
you
look emotionless i'm hearing the hate
but i'm not seeing the hate
rita can you tell i'm happy right now
that's you happy
so i think emotionless is a little bit
of a strong
word to describe the effects of botox
if you have an open conversation with
your provider about what your
desires are for your botox treatment you
can
easily get a treatment that is more
natural looking where you still preserve
some movement in the upper face
it's been exactly eight days since
jordana put my botox in
it hasn't peaked out yet but it's
starting to get tighter on me every
single day
and do i love how it looks i mean i do
do i love how my children can't tell
what i'm thinking
i i love them so you really have to
figure out where you want to run
on that spectrum botox is only used
cosmetically
so botox was actually first fda approved
in 1989
and that was for the use of two medical
disorders of the eye
which is called strabismus and
blepharospasm
it wasn't actually until 2002 that botox
got its first
fda approval for cosmetic indication
well thank goodness those
oculoplastic surgeons were trying to
treat these over
exercising eye muscles because they
that's when they saw that
the lemons in between the eyebrows were
disappearing so it's because of
strabismus that
all of us don't have lines on our face
anymore so botox has actually
been around for over 30 years and it has
over 27 indications most of which
are medical a very common use is
for over sweating so in the underarms
hands and feet
are places because botox does attack
that little muscle on every sweat gland
that helps you to sweat it can turn that
off so that you can decrease sweating
i've also used it medically for
migraines the list
of fda indications for medical botox
is so long only older women get botox
oh no that's so false i was
27 the first time that i put botox into
my crow's feet and
i will tell you it's something that i do
religiously and have done every four and
a half months
for the past decade so i like to say
that botox
is not gender nor is it age specific
there's also a huge increase in male
patients coming in
specifically for their crow's feet
people are
wanting to look their best feel their
best
so botox is not age and then it is not
gender specific botox works right away
huh it's the botox i can't show emotion
for another hour and a half so
truthfully botox can take it takes a
couple of days to kick in
so let's say your botox goes in friday
you're not going to start to really feel
those results into sunday into monday
it takes a full two weeks to peek out
and
at that two-week period incrementally
every single week you'll gain a little
bit of movement back
everybody metabolizes the stuff
differently i think we look natural
i think we're doing a good job